Hi, everyone.
I'm Steven Bazyl from the Google
Drive Developer relations team.
Today I want to talk to you
about a new feature, which
is the integration of Gmail
and Drive with attachments.
To show off this
feature, I just want
to take a look at this
email I sent myself.
It's just a few photos that
I took on my recent vacation
to Alaska.
And if I click on one of
these files, what we see here
is this great
preview experience.
It's the same preview
experience that we've
had in Google Drive itself
for quite some time.
Of course, you can scroll
through these files.
And this one here I want to
do a little bit more with.
If you go down to
the bottom here,
you see this Open With menu.
Here I have a few applications
that I've already installed.
I like Pixlr.
I use that application a lot.
I also have CafePress.
But if I want to try
out something else,
I can, of course, click
Connect More Apps.
And here we see
applications, like PicMonkey,
which is another great
photo editing app.
I can install that and
edit with that as well.
But for now, I wanted
to stick with Pixlr.
So here I'm going to go
back, open with Pixlr,
and in just a few seconds here
we'll see the photo open up.
The cool thing is
with Pixlr they
didn't have to change
anything for this.
This is the same
Drive application
that they've had since we've
had this feature in Drive.
It just now works with Gmail.
So if you've built
a Drive application,
this is a great new
feature for you.
It means a lot more users are
exposed to your application.
And if you haven't gotten
around to building one yet,
you have a lot more
reasons to do so.
I hope you enjoy
this feature, and I
hope it brings a lot more
success to your applications.
Thanks.